c'est une entrée dans un nouveau monde
l'assemblée son hémicycle et solennelle
perchoir une découverte pour benoît
bordât
un peu plus tôt à la gare de dijon le
tout jeune députés pressent le pas
stressé à l'idée de découvrir la grande
scène politique après rentrée des
classes il faut aller à paris chercher
notre matériel remplir un certain nombre
d'informations donc voilà de bon matin
près pour illustrer ce mu un petit peu
de découverte c'est un peu nouveau et
puis on prend progressivement conscience
des choses on rentre dans la fonction on
rentre dans la fonction progressivement
le voilà bien sur les rails paris 10
heures il franchit enfin les portes de
la cour d'honneur un huissier le prend
en charge
une fois à l'intérieur il faut se
repérer dans les couloirs interminables
et trouver le fameux bureau au badge
levage donc le règlement de l'assemblée
nationale
le livret d'accueil les charges pas
des cartes de transport un ordinateur et
une tablette complètent la panoplie du
député de quoi entrer dans le costume
avant d'immortaliser le moment avec
l'indispensable photos officielles c'est
émouvant c'est
on prend pleinement la mesure de ce qui
se passe on prend encore plus conscience
voilà deux
de la fonction des responsabilités
donc voilà il va y avoir une petite
période de rodage début parce qu'on a
aussi beaucoup d'attentes de la part des
gens désormais place au travail dès
demain il aura sa première réunion de
groupe avec la majorité présidentielle